in the previous lecture
we have discussed that machine learning
algorithms can be broadly divided into
three categories
supervised learning unsupervised
learning and reinforcement learning
in supervised learning we give the
computer a data set with what is called
a target variable
that's whether or not the person had
heart disease or did not have heart
disease
we then give a series of input variables
the modeling algorithms automatically
generates the model
which establishes a relationship between
the target and the input variables
in other words you give the inputs and
along with the input you give the
outcome
unsupervised learning is a search for
homogeneous subsets that produces one or
more possible segmentations of the data
that differ by how similar the cases are
within the segment
and how many subsets there are and how
common or rare they are
the whole idea of homogeneous is just
put similar cases together
now the computer will help you do the
search
but you have to decide how similar is
similar enough for your application
you have to decide how many subsets you
want there to be
and you have to decide how rare or
common the subsets are going to be
unsupervised is actually more difficult
for the human analyst than supervised in
many cases
for instance take a look let's just say
we were asking our computer to perform
unsupervised segmentation on these
blocks
should we separate them so that they're
blue and non-blue
or maybe red and non-red should we be
focusing on shape or is that less
important
should we be focusing on size it's
probably impossible to answer outside
some context
so the computer will help group but only
in partnership with a human analyst
that knows what the goal of the
segmentation will be
so sometimes we do see definitions of
unsupervised learning that make it seem
like it's pretty much supervised
but when you can't find a target
variable or you don't have ready access
to a target variable
it's actually a very different set of
goals when we do unsupervised learning
the third area of machine learning is
called reinforcement learning
only recently has this been a source of
confusion mostly because of two
application areas that have gotten a lot
of excitement
technologies like driverless cars and
technologies like the one that was able
to beat the world champion at go
these operate in a very different way at
first
they sound like supervised but they're
quite different
what's happening here is you're not
presenting the algorithm with a very
large number of input and output pairs
rather it's working in an environment
and it's correct and incorrect not for
each row of data
but it's rather rewarded for correct
actions it takes in the environment
this is the kind of technology that
arises for very cool things like
watching a robot stumble
and then as it practices it gets better
next let's try and understand
unsupervised machine learning
put simply this is the process of taking
a lot of unstructured data
running it through lots of compute and
somehow getting structured data out of
it
example let's say that in a room there
are five people talking with each other
that's a lot of unstructured data but
everybody's voice is like a thumb print
so just by having a computer analyze it
we could split that into individual
audio streams
or let's say we have lots of documents
and we wish to be able to categorize
them
but we don't know how many categories
but we want to categorize them
or you got lots of pictures and you want
to find similarities between those
pictures
this is not just recognizing faces so
let's say person x appears in these
pictures
that's a very common application but it
could also be how many pictures are
daytime or nighttime
how many pictures have bright lights in
them how many pictures have modern
buildings versus nature
these are various categories so these
are various examples of unsupervised
machine learning
at a high level you can think of
unsupervised learning as something that
were data points have no labels
associated with them
so you don't know what categories these
will fall into
the goal is to somehow organize the data
to make sense of it
the important point here is that
unsupervised machine learning can often
be a precursor to supervised machine
learning
example that we have five people talking
and we get individual audio streams out
of them
now that you have split those audio
streams perhaps we can try
and find out what language they're
talking in
what is the sentiment we can analyze the
text
try and gain meaning or knowledge out of
what they were talking about
all of that then gets into supervised
machine learning